new details have been released for
gearbox software's new game battle born
after a blog post on the 2k site I'm
Dave and welcome to your badass news
update in addition to the PC
requirements 2k and gearbox confirm that
battle bonds PC version supports
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one controllers
with support for the steam controller
coming after launch the PC version of
battle born will not support 4k or off
size displays at launch but the
developer is actively investigating both
to be added sometime further down the
road also featured in the blog post is
an overview of battle born game modes
and gameplay details among other things
it's confirmed that battle ball will
have a hardcore mode 4 story episodes
that give players unforgiving challenges
although there is no word yet on what
those are players will be rewarded for
their extra efforts as successful
players will earn extra loot and all new
unlockable content the blog post also
covers about abalones co-op support
there is local split-screen for ps4 and
Xbox one that supports 2 players per
system whilst also confirmed that
split-screen players can join any team
with the maximum number of players per
side being 5 be sure to read the full
blog post as it contains many more
details about battle bonds and numerous
roads and gameplay features Papelbon's
open beta begins on April 8 for ps4 and
April 13th for Xbox one and PC so are
you excited for battle born are you
badass enough to play let us know in the
comment section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and for your
gaming news station to GameSpot calm